cette trêve qui est censée avoir
commencé il y a un peu plus de 48 heures
et qui s'est terminé hier à 23h heure
locale minuit heure de Moscou une trêve
qui n'aura pas eu lieu nous sommes
rendus en direction de campian ce qui
nous étions à quelques kilomètres du
front dans des villages récemment
libérés de la région de harkif une
région qui a été occupée jusqu'à la fin
de l'été début de l'automne dernier et
nous avons pu échanger avec des
habitants qui nous disaient cette trêve
n'existe pas comme Ludi qui transportait
des céréales et qui s'est énervé en
entendant parler en entendant ce mot ce
mot de trait et dit mais ce mot n'existe
que dans les médias qu'à la télévision
les tirs sont constants les frappes sont
répétées même chose pour Olga qui disait
encore ce matin on a entendu cinq
frappes donc nous nous sommes rapprochés
avec des soldats du front jusqu'à 2 km
on ne peut pas dire exactement où mais
entre la région de rartif qui donc a été
récemment libéré la région de Louhans
qui a encore temporairement occupé par
les trop Prusses et là des bombardements
systématiques des frappes systématiques
d'un côté comme de l'autre alors quand
nous avons demandé aux soldats ukrainien
mais alors vous non plus vous ne
respectez pas cette rêve ils ont ri ils
ont dit écoutez il y a eu une trêve
soi-disant également en avril qui n'a
jamais été respecté celle-ci on savait
très bien qu'elle n'allait pas non plus
avoir lieu de fait ce n'est pas
seulement que les tirs ont repris à
partir d'un certain moment au milieu de
la tresse et qui n'ont jamais cessé nos
distillent et dans ces conditions nous
n'allons pas nous laisser faire et nous
n'allons pas cesser de riposter des
Russes des Ukrainiens pardon qui nous
ont expliqué que selon eux la stratégie
russe est une stratégie militaire
pouvoir cette trêve ça permettrait de se
déployer de se réorganiser mais aussi
une stratégie de relation publique car
pour le monde et bien selon eux Vladimir
Poutine voudrait se faire passer pour un
bon samaritain pour cette trêve qui
cette trêve de Noël qui n'aura pas eu
lieu et d'ailleurs toutes les personnes
avec qui nous avons parlé dans ces
villages alentours n'ont pas fêter Noël
orthodoxe ils nous disent qu'ils n'ont
tout simplement pas le cœur à